apple vient tout juste de terminer sa
conférence des développeurs pour l'année
2020 la fameuse label du label bbc qui a
lieu tous les ans au mois de juin
et cette année il ya eu encore plaint
d'un autre c'est intéressant dans un
contexte vraiment très particulier à
cause du corona des russes et bien il y
avait personne dans l'audience donc fait
une vidéo qu'ils avaient tourné bien
produite réveil à l'échec
avec plein d'annoncés tout est là dedans
alors bon l'idée aujourd'hui c'est
d'essayer de le voir un peu quels
étaient ces annonces quelles sont les
choses les plus intéressantes et s'il ya
eu que du logiciel est juste une annonce
matériel mais qui n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on va pouvoir avoir et qui pour
moi est peut-être l'info la plus
importante mais qui va être un peu
clipser par les autres je commençais par
sa tenue j'ai commencé par ça tout de
suite
c'est en fait apple va se passer des
services d intel pour tous les
processeurs de ses ordinateurs à venir
il était déjà complètement autonome au
niveau des processeurs au niveau de ceux
des iphone au niveau des ipad au niveau
des montres connectés et là ils vont
plus loin ils le font maintenant sur les
mac on va donc retrouver les apple
silicone les puces d'apple avec
notamment la a12 z bionique qui équipe
en tout cas des machines qui nous ont
montré être fonctionnel et sur les
prochaine génération de macbook de mac
qu'on devrait pouvoir retrouver cette
fois ci lors des annonces du mois de
septembre
d'ailleurs j'invite dès maintenant à
vous abonner pour tout savoir sur les
annonces d'apple les actualités et
nouveautés
on parle bien évidement d'iphone on
parle de watch on parle de plein de
choses d' ipad on parle de mac donc
abonnez vous cliquez ici vous avez la
cloche vous accédez tout comme ça vous
saurez tout donc voilà pour le premier
point qui est vraiment le point le plus
matérielles que je trouve extrêmement
intéressant et tout ça on sera bien
évidemment plus tard alors grosse
nouveauté sur l'iphone avec ios 14
nouvelles réalisations meilleure
optimisation gtech le point qui m'a le
plus intéressé moi ce sont les widgets
qui arriverait au pouvoir complètement
personnaliser son interface est emmené
des widgets parce que je sais pas si
vous êtes utilisateur vous d'un iphone
mais c'est vrai que ça c'est bien mais
voyez bon bout d'un moment on a pleins
d'applications tous les côtés voilà
c'est un petit peu triste mise à part le
fait de créer des groupes on va pas bien
loin
on fait pas grand chose hélas le fait de
pouvoir emmener des widgets ça va amener
vraiment autre chose le fait de pouvoir
notamment affiché son calendrier de voir
ces rendez-vous et
ce traitement rapidement pour moi c'est
vraiment un très gros bénéfices et c'est
vraiment un truc que j'attendais parce
que à force commence à trouver ça un
petit peu tristounet alors effectivement
ces pratiques il ya plein d'intérêt
derrière mais le février de pouvoir voir
mon calendrier avec en gros mais rendez
vous à venir
le fait de voir ma météo c'est vraiment
bien laurent pour en ajouter plein de
choses il y aura des photos je les ai
noté tout ça durant les photos dans les
podcasts il y aura match enfin tout ce
que vous avez sur votre iphone pourra
venir s'intégrer dans les widgets et
c'est vraiment une excellente nouvelle
donc c'est vraiment fière c'est le
premier point qui pour moi en tout cas
mike plus hype et on peut dire ça comme
ça qui pourra amener plus de choses en
tout cas en terme d' usage aux pommes je
trouverais maintenant ce qu'ils
appellent la plage brerhi c'est le fait
de regrouper toutes vos applications par
thématiques par exemple facebook twitter
et compagnie dans la partie réseaux
sociaux tout ce qui va être partie
productivité à droite à gauche ça vos
icônes vont être classées
automatiquement vous n'avez pas le faire
et ça s'est vraiment bien ça vient
porter déjà un point essentiel est le
plus important ça va éviter que vous
ayez voyez des pages à rallonge comme ça
a donc toutes vos applications et nous
on s'embête des points à venir les
regrouper au sein de groupes là vous
allez vous groupes qui vont se faire
automatiquement vous allez pouvoir
choisir de ne pas avoir autant de paf
d'être une page de pages avec des
widgets et plus importants et ensuite
tout va être regroupés au niveau de ces
dossiers intelligents gérer
automatiquement par apple ça va venir
complètement changé la façon dont vous
allez utiliser un os et révolutionnaire
petit peu l'usagé des iphone et ça pour
moi c'est le point le plus important
j'attendais depuis très longtemps et
chauffe que c'est vraiment bien c'est
permettra d'emmener les iphone encore
plus loin dans un usage encore plus
pertinent encore plus performant et
encore plus personnalisé et un peu moins
froid qu'à voir toutes ces icônes qui
arrivé comme ça et qui voit là à l'epa
était pas forcément ils pratiquèrent
hyper intéressant je sais pas ça
d'apporter du mieux en termes
d'addiction aux smartphones le fait
qu'on ait toujours vous allez voir les
nouvelles apps peut-être ça peut être
vraiment intéressant d'ailleurs j'en ai
parlé ça dans le podcast vous invite à
aller l'écouter je vous ai mis les liens
en bas dans la description pour
découvrir le podcast où on parle
justement d'élections au smart phone
et c'est très intéressant dans la
librairie y aura aussi des suggestions
des applications que vous pourriez est
en tout cas censé utiliser prochainement
les applications les plus récemment
ajoutée avec une vraie classification
intelligente passé pas mal il ya aussi
une nouveauté qui s'appelle le picture
in picture par exemple vous regardez un
film
et bien vous allez pouvoir venir le
rétrécir pouvoir continuer à naviguer à
travailler à chatter a collaboré tout
encore dans votre film vous le déplacer
vous agrandissez c'est pas mal plutôt
intéressant pourquoi pas si rick et
mieux intégrée avec une icône que vous
allez trouver en bas syrie toujours plus
intelligent vous avez une application de
traduction aussi qui arrivent ça c'est
un truc qu'on retrouve déjà dans
d'autres applications apple intègre en
direct plutôt bien vous allez parler
dans votre langue sale traduit et vous
mettez lecture que la personne en face
puisse comprendre dans sa langue
bon pourquoi pas ça c'est plutôt bien il
ya aussi des choses qui ont été revus et
corrigés au niveau des messages
je passe rapidement parce que c'est un
petit peu moins intéressant au niveau de
mars ce qui était surtout intéressant
qui a ajouté c'est le vélo avec les
pistes cyclables notamment aussi pour la
voiture électrique et pouvoir trouver
aux bornes de recharge et faire votre
itinéraire à pont-de-vaux bornes de
recharge ça c'est bien on va plus loin
aussi au niveau de carpes l'est avec un
nouveau fond d'écran avec le tout de
déverrouiller votre automobile grâce au
nfc de vos smartphones notamment avec
bmw donc wait
une fois de plus dans l' ultra premium
vous arrivez tac vous rentrez votre
voiture voulait des marques de
smartphones et si quelqu'un veut pouvoir
l'utiliser faut lui partager votre clé
numérique à distance il la reçoit avec
les usages qui a pouvoir en faire ça
tout ça plutôt bien se trouvant dans le
voile est plutôt intéressant l'app store
aussi qui est améliorée voilà pour les
grandes nouveautés du côté des usa on a
des nouveautés du côté d' ipad ios on va
reprendre un peu l'idée si vous voulez
qu'on retrouve au niveau des os avec et
notamment les widgets il ya une
amélioration au niveau de la partie
photo au niveau de syrie au niveau de la
recherche
vous allez tout pouvoir venir chercher
dans votre zone de recherche de votre
ipad
que ce soit les messages soient vos
emails que ce soit vos contacts vous
retrouvez tout en un seul et même
endroit il ya un truc est aussi
intéressant avec le pen seule avec le
pen s'il arrive à faire bon accent
qu'est ce qu'ils appellent scribble
alors squibb elle en fait vous avez dire
c'est que sa vie reconnaître de façon
très intelligente votre écriture
vous écrivez vous pouvez le convertir en
texte va vous aider à améliorer ce que
vous venez de dessiner décidé une flèche
vous fera une très belle flèche au lieu
d'abord un petit dessin des fois un peu
oui comme en tout cas je pourrais le
faire donc la côte est toujours plus
intelligent avec du copier coller depuis
votre texte manuscrit ça c'est vraiment
bien pour moi qui ait vraiment de liga
derrière qui va reconnaître votre
écriture et qui va être capable de
l'interpréter on va un peu plus loin un
truc qui est vraiment intéressant par
contre c'est le software au niveau des
aires podz et notamment au niveau des
reposes pour l'heure pour tous les
reposes vous allez pouvoir un sweat
intelligent entre différents appareils
vous êtes sur votre ipad vous regardez
un film paf on vous appelle sur votre
iphone vauvert potes vont toucher
directement sur votre iphone vous avez
eu notification très importante sur
votre mac
et maintenant ce qui est vraiment bien
est ce qu'ils ont fait au niveau des erp
aux pros c'est ce qu'on va appeler à ce
qu'ils appellent tout cas le spatial
spatiale audio c'est de la
spatialisation imaginez vous êtes allé
voir post pro il vous regardez un film
sur votre smartphone sur votre table et
notre ordi peu importe ça va vous
permettre d'avoir une vraie
spatialisation comme si vous aviez un 5
points alors qu'en fait vous avez juste
voir post pro ce qui est déjà très bien
mais est là où ça va encore plus loin
ils vont utiliser le gyroscope et
l'accéléromètre dire que lorsque vous
allez bouger la tête comme ça votre
écran reste devant et bien votre seconde
va pas se décaler avec une source
principale ici vous ai vraiment garder
la source principale en face donc si
vous avez une voiture qui se déplacent
comme ça que vous tournez la tête la
voiture était de faire toujours comme ça
et non pas comme ça je trouve que
l'expérience est intéressante permet
d'aller plus loin par rapport à ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui en tout cas en
terme d'immersion en termes d coûte deux
films maintenant on va directement par
les deux watch on va parler de votre
monde connecté et notamment du sport
alors on va toujours plus loin en termes
de sport on a de nouvelles applications
qui viennent d'arriver toujours plus de
partage on va également tourner dans
l'idée de max avec les pistes cyclables
vous allez pouvoir retrouver dans votre
montre au niveau du sport vous allez
retrouver de la danse du hip hop les
compagnies pourquoi passaient plutôt
bien et on renie hommes à l'application
elle s'appellera plus activity mais
fitness à voir comment il va être
traduite en français toute une partie
qui est développé avec une application
sommeil qui va venir vous accompagner au
moment d'aller vous coucher ça va
travailler de pair avec votre smartphone
vous définissez votre toucher à ma
hauteur de coucher ça vous emmène tout
doucement avoir des lumières plus douce
ça vous coupe tout moment d'aller vous
coucher
il voulait pouvoir dormir avec votre
monde ça va traquer bien évidemment
votre sommeil vous allez voir une
interface avec juste l'heure rien
d'autre pas de distraction et si vous
bougez selva pas l'actionner faudra
venir taper dessus donc ça veut dire que
vous êtes réveillé pas pouvoir voir leur
et lorsque vous allez vous réveiller et
bien d'autres à la rva soyez soit montre
bon fond ça plutôt bien ça va dans le
bon sens mais en tout cas je sais que je
suis pas trés trés clients de ça parce
que je ne dors pas que ma montre j'ai
besoin d'avoir le bras libre peut-être
pas pour moi mais peut-être pour vous
dire dites le moi en bas en commentaire
à une autre application qui est assez
intéressante et qui est vraiment dans
l'est
du temps notamment que vides vous avez
une application pour le lavage des mains
votre montre de façon intelligente va
reconnaître par rapport aux mouvements
que vous faites que vous êtes en train
de vous laver les mains elle va donc
vous faire un décompte de 20 secondes 24
20 30 secondes sa maison vous affichez
le temps qu'il vous reste lorsque vous
vous lavez les mains
elle va donc vibrer lorsque c'est
terminé et si vous n'avez pas être un
énième vous dis continuez de vous laver
les mains vous êtes un petit peu sale
apple a également fait un très gros
focus au niveau de la vie privée au fait
de garder des données privées à
l'intérieur de votre smartphone au
maximum et non pas forcément dans le
club a capté que les données
essentielles et à vraiment venir vous
sécuriser et en faisant qui est une
vraie transparence et que vous gardiez
vous toujours contrôle de vos données
et même lorsque vous avez navigué sur
votre navigateur et notamment sur safari
savoir ce qui se passe dans votre
navigateur savoir qu'est ce qui va être
traqués et nous en soyons tout le temps
alerté lui un focus qui était lui aussi
sur la maison avec l'application home je
passe très très rapidement toujours
pouvoir contrôler ses éclairages sa
caméra bon plutôt bien et une belle mise
à jour sur mac os avec macos big show
big sûr est super vous le dit comme vous
voulez dans mon big four sans promettre
plutôt pas mal avec un design amélioré
un petit peu plus minimaliste beaucoup
plus intuitif avec un control center qui
est revu bonjour ça plutôt bien
à voir et à tester bien évidemment sur
la nouvelle version sera emmenée à en
reparler avec des messages qui sont
améliorées maps une fois de plus
amélioré par exemple pour les annonces
qui ont été faites du côté d'apple on le
voit le gros focus est toujours une fête
plus
eyeos c'était quelque chose de très
particulier de d'abord personne dans
l'audience padano ce produit parce que
ça aurait été compliqué vu que lorsque
vous avez une présentation produit faut
que les journalistes puissent être là
pour soi prendre des photos soient
filmés pourquoi en tout cas voir les
produits et pouvoir vous en parler et là
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas à
voir comment sera la présentation au
mois de septembre a notamment au niveau
de tout ce qui va être hardware les
iphone probablement l'apple watch
peut-être un nouveau mac allez savoir en
tout cas on verra tout ça on en
reparlera au mois de septembre vous avez
donc dès maintenant à vous abonner si
pas déjà le cas en tout cas moi ce que
je retiens et ce qui m'intéresse le plus
dans tout ça il ya je vous dis hein le
fait qu'apple fasse eux-mêmes maintenant
leur propre puce pour l'ordinateur et
c'est très intéressant pour le marché
noir que les puces d'intel ne vaut plus
du tout intégré ça va donc changer des
choses pour intel et notamment aux
tables de
de vente ça c'est le premier point est
le deuxième point je vous le dis je
trouve vraiment le plus intéressant
c'est le fait d'avoir autre chose au
niveau des os les widgets la librairie
on en reparlera très très prochainement
et je vous dirai ce que j'en pense sur
ceux d'en bas beaucoup d'amour prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]